(whimsical music)
- [Narrator] This mosque's
distinct red and white patterns
and tall minarets
can be seen from every part
of this Sri Lankan town.
Jami Ul-Alfar, known
locally a the 'Red Mosque',
is located in Colombo, Sri Lanka.
It was commissioned in 1908
by Indian Muslims who
traveled for business
and needed a place of
worship while in Sri Lanka.
The designer and builder
was H.L. Saibu Labbe,
and the original structure
only took one year to build
and was completed in 1909.
He was influenced by
Indo-Saracenic architecture,
which is a hybrid of
Indian and Islamic styles.
The best example of this
is the mosque's pomegranate-shaped domes.
The mosque started small; only
500 to 1,000 people gathered.
But it has since grown and
expanded to be six floors
to accommodate around 10,000 worshipers.
Apart from being a major tourist
destination for visitors,
Jami Ul-Alfar is also
the main place of worship
for Sri Lankan Muslims.